الفنان ماجد المصري بيطل على الجمهور في
هذا الموسم الرمضاني بدور ضرب نار في
مسلسل ضرب نار وعمل عامل اصداء من اولى
حلقاته ومن قبل حتى اولى الحلقات ماجد
كمان كان شوق الجمهور للدار
مسلسل ضرب نار خلي بالكم فالقضوا يطلع كده
تطلع كده انا مش مسؤول كل سنه وانتم طيبين
ماجد المصري
ماجد المصري بيلعب في المسلسل دور زيدان
رجل الاعمال المتزوج وعنده بنت لكن بيوقع
في حب مهره اللي بتقوم بدوره ياسمين عبد
العزيز واللي قلبها معه احمد العوضي اللي
هو جابر في المسلسل ومن هنا بتبدا
الخلافات والصراعات المسلسل
اللي بياكل من تحت لتحت لازم يفهم الاصول
شغل الشمال لاصول احنا صعايده ولا انت
رجاله
مع زيدان ما ينفعش يخون ومعنى من القاهره
النجم ماجد المصري اهلا فيك معانا وكل عام
وانت بالف خير ماجد
بكل الساده المشاهدين وكل سنه وحضراتكم
طيبين ورمضان كريم يا رب ان شاء الله
علينا وعليك يا رب
اتكلمت انت عن هذا المسلسل قبل ما ينزل
وقلت انه دور مختلف ليش مختلف بالنسبه لك
شخصيه زيدان شخصيه محيره شويه
يعني دايما مش هتبقي عارفه اذا كان هو طيب
ولا هو شرير يعني كيف الحلقه الثانيه
بيقتل صح
وقع في حب مهره
احنا مش عارفينه زيدان ده ايه حكايته
بالظبط يعني هو شخصيه بالنسبه لي انا وده
يمكن كان سبب موافقتي على الدور انه انه
مش شخصيه ماشيه على تراك واحد يعني هي
شخصيه فيها ازدواجيه شويه عارفه ازاي انا
بالنسبه شخصيه جديده قابلتني على الورق من
من
الكاتب الموهوب الكبير الاستاذ ناصر عبد
الرحمن
ما قدرتش طبعا ان انا اتراجع لحظه واحده
يعني
وحتى يعني نحن شفناك في المسلسل انت عامل
في البدايه انه بيبين انه رجل الاعمال
اللي غني مره وكده بعدين فجاه لقيناك فجاه
طلعت ابن بلد ابن بلد يعني يعني
تمام وفجاه العيون دمعت قدام ياسمين يعني
صراحه ايه لا لا عامل لنا شويه كده يعني
يعني خلينا نقول لخبطه كيف كان العمل بس
مع ياسمين واحمد خصوصا حيصير بينكم كثير
ضرب نار يبدو ضربه على الشاشه طبعا مش
يعني مش
حبايبي واخوات طبعا ياسمين طبعا
اختي وطبعا يعني بيننا علاقه طيبه طول
العمر الحمد لله وكان احمد كمان واحمد
كمان شخصيه محترمه جدا جدا واخ عزيز وغير
يعني
واحنا على المستوى الفني طبعا عايزين نطلع
حاجه تسعد الناس والناس تشوفها وتتبسط
ويبقى كل واحد بيلعب في التراك بتاعه كل
واحد بيلعب شخصيه مختلفه
جابر جديد بيلعب شخصيه مختلفه مهرب والليل
شخصيه مختلفه زيدان شخصيه كل واحد له يعني
بس هنا المؤلف يعني هو ازاي بيخلي الخطوط
دي تتلاقى مع بعضها ويحصل ما بينهم
الخلاف والحب والدموع والهدر ونشوف بقى
لسه مش عايز احلق طبعا
الناس بيقولوا انك دايما بتطلع في دور
الشرير ليش دائما
انت وكل اللي بيعرفوك بيقولوا انه انت دمك
زي العسل
يعني لمهره وفي حته تانيه لا زي ما انت
قلت قتل واحد احترت صراحه مش عارفه يعني
بس يعني
مش ممكن يعني عشان شافها مره ولا اتنين
فرح لها البيت يعني
ضربت العكره فخلاص لا اكيد طبعا هو عينه
على بكره من زمان وده لسه هنعرفه يعني
طريقه الكتابه بتاعه الاستاذ ناصر عبد
الرحمن بيعمل ايه
بيعمل مثلا مشهد فممكن مشاهد يقول لك ايه
طب وهو لحق يحبها امتى ولكن هو بيجاوب على
كل الاسئله دي بس لسه لما نكمل اوكي لما
نكمل العبره والنهايه يعني لازم نتفرج
الاول عن عمل كده على طول بسرعه من الاول
الحلقه 10 حلقات
لازم نتفرجها على المسلسل كله وبعد ما
نتناقش ونقول رايي طب والستات على تويتر
وفيسبوك وكده زعلانين كيف رفضتك مهره في
حمله كبيره في حمله كبيره لمساندتك كيف
رفضت تتزوج منك مهره امورك ماشيه مع
المعجبات
الحمد لله
ههه ربنا يخليك يعني بشكرهم طبعا
وعايزهم طبعا يعني يكتبوا كتير طبعا عشان
مهره توافق يعني
[ضحك]
لا هو في امل يتغير الموضوع
خالص
هو بيتقدم لها كرجل
وكان حتى اسلوبه معها ما فيهوش تعالي او
الاداء نفسه اه يعني راجل طبيعي جدا بجد
بيتكلم بمنتهى المشاعر بيحب واحده
بغض النظر بقى هي في نفس المستوى او اقل
او او لاخره مش ده الموضوع خالص الموضوع
قال الراجل ده صادق ولا رايح يشتري فقرها
عشان هو مليونير او عنده مصانع المصانع
بتاعته ودي مجرد واحده بتشتغل عنده لا هو
بيحبها فعلا فعلا بيحبها واحبها بجد
مختلفه يعني قلت لك انك مختلفه لما رفضته
ايوه لا لا كان مشهد مؤثر يا ماجد انا
فاكرك بفصل
بس خليني كمان انجلد على رمضان هذا كان
الكل متوقع كمان هتكون موجود في مسلسل اخر
يمكن مع النجمه غاده عبد الرازق بعدين
قالوا انك انسحبت بعدين يعني هل كان في
هذا المشروع ولا بس كلام اعلامي
[موسيقى]
هو بيعتمد على نفسه
وهيعرف يوصل ان شاء الله
ولو في فرصه انا هقدمه اتقبلت قبل ما
اتقبلش انا ما عنديش مشكله خالص لان
شغلتنا ما فيهاش مجاملات بمعنى يعني لو
كان مثلا ابناء الراحل الاستاذ صالح سليم
مثلا بيعرفوا يلعبوا كوره كان وقتها رئيس
نادي الاهلي كان زمانهم بيلعبوا كوره لكن
الجمهور مش هيقبل فانا لو سيبني بيعرف
يمثل الجمهور هيقبله ما بيعرفش يمثل
ولو لو اي فنان النهارده تواجد على الساحه
الفنيه وهو والده فنان مثلا او من العائله
فنيه صدقيني هو لو مش شاطر
مش هيعرف نفسه المنافسه قويه جدا عارفه
ازاي لكن لو عندنا لو عدينا كل اللي
موجودين دلوقتي مثلا محمد عادل امام نجم
هي كبيره وناجح جدا جدا كريم محمود عبد
العزيز برضو نفس الموضوع احمد زكي رحمه
الله عليه المكان موجود الله يرحمه طبعا
احمد السعدني اه طبعا يعني
هنا بنقول لا عشان ولاد فنانين لا في
جينات موجوده يا جماعه وفي ناس من بره
الوسط واهاليها مش فنانين وعباقره في
التمثيل وفي الاخراج وفي السيناريو وكل
حاجه دي موهبه ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيمني
بها على البني ادم ما نقدرش ان احنا نتكلم
او نقول لهم ليه لا هو شاطر هيعرف يثبت
وجوده
في السوق بالظبط
طب انا بتمنى لك طبعا التوفيق والمسلسل
حماسي جدا وبقول للناس يعني يتفرجوا عليه
لانه فعلا كل حلقه على الحلقه بيزيد الدوز
يعني اكثر فانا متحمسه يعني
واحده واحده لان انا لو هتكلم على شخصيه
زيدان انا مش عايز احلق الشخصيه ولكن
بوعدهم ان هم هيشوفوني انا شخصيا طبعا
المسلسل كله الحمد لله ناجح جدا جدا جدا
جدا جدا الحمد لله انا دلوقتي عشان اللقاء
انا بتكلم على شخصيه زيدان الشخصيه مختلفه
عليا جديده على المشاهد يعني انا حاسس ان
انا بقدم حاجه جديده وده شيء بصراحه في
متعه بالنسبه لي انا شخصيا يعني يا رب
ان شاء الله وبقول لكل المعجبات يعني
يحاولوا
دماغ مهره شويه ايوه رجعت للمعجبات يعني
نقطه ضعف
حلوه شفافيه والصراحه اوكي
انا ادري طبعا شكرا لك يا ماجد نورتنا
اليوم بالتوفيق جدا شكرا مع السلامه مع
السلامه